مازال اسم اللاعب المغربي اشرف حكيمي لاعب
منتخب المغرب ونادي باريس سان جيرمان
عنوان رئيسي في الاخبار والناس بتتابع
بترقب تطورات اتهام فتالوبي الاغتصاب
البنت قالت انه في يناير بداوا يتكلموا
على انستجرام وفي 25 فبراير اتفقوا يلتقوا
وبعتلها لبيت وهناك اغتصبها وعرفت تدفه في
الاخر وتهرب وتطلب صحبتها بمسج انه تيجي
تاخذهم والبنت للتذكير قالت للشرطه انها
بتثبت حالها بس وانما تبغى ترفع دعوه او
تشتكي لكن السلطات قررت انها تحقق في
الموضوع لشهره حكيمي ولخطوره القصه
فاستجوبوا البنت والخميس استجوب حكيمي
كمان اللي نفدتهما من اول يوم وبعد
التحقيق والاستجواب النيابه وجهت رسميا
لحكيمي تهمه الاغتصاب ووضع تحت المراقبه
والاشراف القضائي ومنعوه انه يتواصل مع
الفتاه ويتكلم معاها لكن في نفس الوقت
قالت انه مسموح له يغادر الاراضي الفرنسيه
محاميه حكيمي صرحت للاعلام بعد توجيه
التهم وقالت انه موكلها ضحيه لمحاوله
ابتزاز من قبل الفتاه اللي مو متعاونه مع
العداله وانها مرضت تعمل فحوص نفسيه وطبيه
ولكن محاميه الفتاه قالت انه كلها بالكلام
مو مهم وانه موكلتها لسه مو جاهزه انها
تواجه حكيمي الشخص الثاني اللي بياكد
براءه حكيمي هي والدته اللي اشتهرت بشكل
كبير في مونديال قطر وشفناهم مع بعض في
اغلب الصور والاحتفالات السيده سعيده قالت
انه قلبها بيقول لها انه ابنها بريء وقالت
انها سالته واقسم لها ببراءته وقالت انه
الناس كلها بتشهد باخلاقه وتساءلت كيف
ممكن يعمل كده في غياب مرته والبيت فيه
حراس وكاميرات مراقبه تصريحات والده حكيمي
جاءت الرغم تاكيدها انه محاميته طلبت من
كل افراد العائله عدم الادلاء بتصري
للاعلام في الوقت الراهن حكيمي للان متهم
فقط لا تمت ادانته ولا شيء ومثل ما كلنا
نعرف المتهم بريء حتى تثبتو لكن رغم هذا
الشيء في معسكرات كبيره اونلاين حاسمه
الموضوع وجالسه بتتخانق عليه في شريحه
خلاص ادانت حكيمي وبتنتقدوا اشد الانتقاد
وبالدين وبتستنكر وشريحه ثانيه لا بتدافع
باستماته عنه وبتسخر من البنت اللي مشتكيه
وروايتها وبتجزم انه حكيمي ضحيه ابتزاز
طيب احنا معانا من باريس مراسل العربيه
فادي الدهوك والمتابع للقضيه من اول يوم
اهلا فيك معانا فادي هل عندك المزيد من
التفاصيل عن التحقيقات اللي جرت مع اطراف
القضيه
اهلا ساره الجديد في هذه القضيه هو ان
القضاء الان منكب على فحص عدد من
المداولات جرت بين ثلاثه اطراف بين اشرف
حكيمي من جهه والشاب التي تتهمه وبين
الشاب التي تتهمه واحدى صديقاتها في هذه
المحادثات ما يخص اشرف حكيمي وهذه الفتاه
قام اشرف حكيمي بحسب المعلومات التي
نشرتها عدد من الصحف الفرنسيه من مصادر
مقربه من التحقيق قام بتسليم كل هذه
المحادثات الى القضاء ليطلع عليها لكن
المفاجاه ان الشاب التي تتهمه لم تقم
بتسليم المحادثات من جانبها وقالت انها
قامت بحذف حساب انستجرام التي الذي كانت
تتحدث معه
عبره مع حكيمي من جهه ثانيه المحادثات
بينها وبين صديقتها هي قالت في الشهاده
التي قدمتها لمركز الشرطه عندما
ذهبت اليه في اليوم التالي من الواقعه
قالت انها وصلت الى هناك قرابه الساعه
الواحده بعد منتصف الليل اشرف حكيمي ارسل
لها سياره اجره مكثت في شقته نحو ساعه هنا
بدا
بملامستها بتقبيلها قبل ان يقوم باغتصابها
بحسب روايتها وهنا قامت بالاتصال باحدى
صديقاتها التي جاءت لكي تنقذها من هذا
الموقف بحسب ما تقول السلطات او القضاء
يحاول فهم بعض الرسائل يقولون او تم
استخدام عباره من قبل المصادر التي سربت
هذه الاخبار ان هناك لغز في هذه المبادلات
بين الشاب التي تتهم اشرف حكيمي وبين
صديقتها يحاولون فك بعض هذه الرسائل هناك
لغه غير مفهومه تم التحدث فيها ربما تكون
لغه لغه او كلام بين اصدقاء عبارات تستخدم
بشكل خاص بين اصدقاء يحاولون فهمها وهذا
هو الامر المهم والملح بالدرجه الاولى حتى
الان في هذه القضيه
يعني في وسط هذا
الغموض اللي حاصل وفي وسط الكلام انه
الفتاه رافضه الفحص الطبي ورفضه الفحص
النفسي والموضوع يعني عدى عليه وقت كيف
ممكن وهي طبعا ناكد كمان ونرجع نذكر انه
البنت مو رافعه دعوه هذا حق عام كيف يمكن
اثبات التهمه اصلا على اشرف حكيمي
حتى الان كل ما يحصل في هذه القضيه هو
ادعاءات او هو اقوال هذه الشابه
ويقع المسؤوليه لاثبات هذه الادعاءات على
الطرف المدعي على محاميتها هذه المساله
اضافت تعقيدات كثيره جدا على القضيه لانها
اولا ترفض مواجهه اشرف حكيمي ترفض ايضا ان
تسلم او ان تقوم برفع شكوى رسميه ضده هو
لا يواجه شكوى بالاغتصاب وانما هناك تحقيق
او تحقيق تلقائي في قضيه من هذا النوع لكن
ايضا هي ترفض الخضوع الى فحوصات طبيه كان
يمكن ان تكشف بما لا يدع مجالا للشك انها
تعرضت للاغتصاب لانها توجهت في اليوم
التالي فقط من هذه القضيه الى مركز الشرطه
لكنها ترفض اجراء هذه الفحوصات هذه القضيه
قد تؤثر على اشخاص كثيرين حقيقه ليس فقط
على اشرف حكيمي على عائلته من جهه على
نادي باريس سان جيرمان حيث اقف الان هنا
امام هذا النادي وخصوصا ايضا على صديق
اشرف حكيمي نجم النادي كيليان مبابي الذي
يلازم اشرف حكيمي في كل الوقت يذهبان
اينما ذهب احدهما سوف يكون الاخر متواجد
يلتقطان الصور يقضيان معظم العطلات مع
بعضهما البعض وهذه المساله ستكون حساسه
جدا للجميع حتى ان النادي هناك اخبار تقول
ان الفريق الفني للنادي ممتعه قليلا من
سلوك اشرف حكيمي لان النادي اختار دعم
لاعبه ليس ضد هذه السيده وليس لاثبات
براءته ولكن لانه الان هو في طور الاتهام
والمتهم بريء حتى تثبت ادانته لذلك هم
يمتعضون من سلوك اشرف حكيمي لانه يتعامل
مع المساله وكان لا شيء ضده لا يواجه هذه
التهمه هو يتصرف بشكل طبيعي
يقوم بالتقاط الصور وبالمزاح خلال
التدريبات وهذا ما اثار نوع من الغضب في
صفوف اداره النادي طيب على العموم المدرب
مدرب باريس سان جيرمان امس سئل فيه
المؤتمر الصحفي وطلب من الصحفيين عدم
توجيه اي اسئله عن اشرف حكيمي او ما يحدث
له حاليا او هذه القضيه تحديدا على العموم
طبعا لانه لا زال الموضوع في طور التحقيق
وحنتابع هذه القضيه اكيد بنشكرك فادي
الدهوك مراسل العربيه من باريس على هذه
المعلومات شكرا لك